hi I'm Anna Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're going to look at how a young
man left a secure job that his father
wanted him to take to follow his passion
in the sporting world he went on to
build one of the most recognizable
brands in the world this is a story of
Nike founder Phillip Knight and the top
three lessons that you can learn from
his success Phillip Knight is the
co-founder and chairman of Nike growing
up in Portland Oregon Knight discovered
he had a love for running and went to
train with the legendary track coach
Bill Bowerman at the University to
coordinate in addition to coaching
Bowerman was experimenting with creating
new types of shoes and night field
tested them on the track form after
graduating Knight went to graduate
school at Stanford and sign up for a
small business class he had to create a
business plan in the class and thought
back the Bowerman's shoes in his
business plan Knight developed a
blueprint for superior athletic shoes
which could be produced cheaply in Japan
after taking a job as an accountant to
make his father happy and hating it
Knight flew to Japan to find a factory
to make his shoes he returned home to
create a partnership with Bowerman they
each invested five hundred dollars into
the business and named it Blue Ribbon
sports later changed to Nike in its
first year the company sold only three
hundred and sixty four dollars worth of
shoes but Knight was determined to make
the company work and stuck with it until
it did today Nike brings in almost
twenty billion dollars in revenue
Knights stake in the company gives him
an estimated net worth of twelve point
seven billion dollars making him the
60th richest person in the world by
having the courage to lead the job that
his father wanted me to take Knight was
able to start his own business and
eventually built one of the most
recognizable companies in the world to
help you courageously grow your business
here are three options you
for billowed night action item number
one have a clear focus as entrepreneurs
it's often hard to stick on your path
when you're not getting the momentum you
are hoping for or when things seem to be
falling apart around you but almost
every business owner has to go through
those dark days to get to the light at
the end of the tunnel and you need to
have the faith and courage to stick to
your vision and say completely focus on
doing what you set out to do as nike
grew Knight had to decide what the focus
of his business would be should he
expand to get into the fashion business
he had such success sponsoring athletes
should he expand and start sponsoring
other celebrities Knight decided that
for his company to continue growing he
would have to have a clear focus and
what he wanted the company to be it
would make it easier for him to make
decisions and also allow his team to
work towards a common goal
according to Knight we wanted Nike to be
the world's best sports and fitness
company once you say that you have a
focus you don't end up making wingtips
or sponsoring the next Rolling Stones
World Tour were not in the fashion
business we're in the sports business
and there's a big difference
action item number two think of business
as war the business world is very
competitive and some industries are more
cutthroat than others if you're offering
a new product or service that you're
hoping will take customers away from
your competition expect that those
competitors will fight back hard have a
plan to beat them and to start winning
their market share being a former
athlete himself Knight loved competition
and relished the chance to compete in
the business world night treats business
as war and has instilled within his
company a healthy dislike of its
competitors always trying to one-up his
competition when Reebok went to the
expense of sponsoring the entire Atlanta
Olympic Games Nike sponsored just two
top athletes but gained much more
valuable coverage in the Reebok who is
also his competitive streak that made
him want to sign a 20 year old Stanford
golfer named Tiger Woods before his
competition could it cost Knight over 40
million dollars but it was a price tag
well worth it in order to keep his
golfing prodigy out of the hands of his
competitors Nike is a very competitive
organization and Knight wouldn't have it
any other way
according to Knight sports is natural
instinctive competitive and in the end
rewarding all of us at Nike get to earn
11 in that world a world that is easy to
believe in business is war without
bullets action item number three just do
it the single thing that differentiates
entrepreneurs from everyone else is that
you went for it
you left the security of a steady
paycheck to venture into the unknown for
your chance to determine your own
destiny you need to keep this attitude
in mind as you grow your business don't
be afraid of making mistakes you won't
be able to do anything significant if
there isn't a risk of failure Nike is
known for its slogan just do it and it's
a statement that accurately reflects how
Phillip Knight acts as an entrepreneur
he's always taking chances is willing to
fail and pushes the conventional limits
to accomplish his goals a great example
is his relationship with basketball
superstar Michael Jordan in 1984 Knight
signed a young Jordan to a sponsorship
deal it was a big risk as Jordan was
only 21 years old and was
just breaking into the league the idea
of players being sponsored was also a
new phenomenon and was a risky and
unproven concept the deal proved to be a
huge success for Nike and provided a big
publicity and sales boost for the
company if night was afraid to just do
it if he had been afraid to make a
mistake the deal would have never
happened
according to Knight the trouble in
America is not that we are making too
many mistakes but they were making too
few and just do it to finish up this
video I wanted to share one of my
favorite true stories about Phillip
Knight and some of his best bolts in
1972 Knight decided his company Blue
Ribbon sports needed a new name and a
new logo Knight like the name dimension
six but a staff disagreed one employee
suggested Nike after the Greek goddess
of victory Knight then paid $35 to
Carolyn Davidson a University of Oregon
student to design the now-famous swoosh
logo at the time Knight said I don't
love it but it'll grow on me he was
under a deadline to pick a logo so he
went with it and a new company was born
you
thank you for joining me for another
edition of all in the masters if you
enjoyed the video please give it a
thumbs up below I also love to hear your
thoughts and feedback if you want to
leave a comment and stay tuned for the
next episode